Speaker 1: So we're going to speak about a very
Speaker 1: difficult and challenging subject today or
Speaker 1: tonight, wherever you are the subject of
Speaker 1: non-duality.
Speaker 1: This is a very mysterious and often
Speaker 1: ambiguous word or statement or definition
Speaker 1: of reality.
Speaker 1: So for all seekers of enlightenment, this
Speaker 1: whole notion of non-duality is very popular.
Speaker 1: Non-duality means oneness, and I want to
Speaker 1: try and talk about my understanding of what
Speaker 1: that actually means, not only as a
Speaker 1: metaphysical and esoteric truth or
Speaker 1: fundamental reality, but also how, even
Speaker 1: more importantly, I want to talk about how
Speaker 1: we can best relate to non-duality if we
Speaker 1: want to, if we're seeking to awaken to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness, if we want to not
Speaker 1: only understand it intellectually but
Speaker 1: actually experience the truth of what it
Speaker 1: actually means, which is the whole point.
Speaker 1: There's a very challenging, serious
Speaker 1: question of how do we relate to this whole
Speaker 1: question of what the ultimate truth is
Speaker 1: supposed to be.
Speaker 1: Not an easy, it's not easy, and that's what
Speaker 1: I want to try and spend some time working
Speaker 1: on that with everybody, but starting at the
Speaker 1: beginning.
Speaker 1: I met with everybody, but starting at the
Speaker 1: I hear a lot of people speak about
Speaker 1: non-duality as meaning oneness, but I'm
Speaker 1: never quite sure what it actually means
Speaker 1: when people see, because often when people
Speaker 1: speak about oneness it's said rather
Speaker 1: casually as oh yeah, everything is one.
Speaker 1: And.
Speaker 1: And it's said rather casually as oh yeah,
Speaker 1: everything is one.
Speaker 1: And I wonder, when we speak casually about
Speaker 1: something like this, if we actually know
Speaker 1: what we're talking about.
Speaker 1: More often than not, it's kind of a
Speaker 1: throwaway concept.
Speaker 1: Non-duality, as I've understood it and as I
Speaker 1: as my guru revealed to me, is ultimately
Speaker 1: it's a great mystery.
Speaker 1: And non-duality is something that we can
Speaker 1: experience, but it's something that's very
Speaker 1: difficult to understand with the mind.
Speaker 1: So this is a very dualistic challenge in a
Speaker 1: way, if non-duality or the ultimate truth
Speaker 1: of oneness, the oneness of all things,
Speaker 1: something we can experience deeply.
Speaker 1: Because it said, of course, that the
Speaker 1: experience of non-duality or oneness, the
Speaker 1: ultimate truth, can radically liberate us
Speaker 1: at the level of the heart and level of the
Speaker 1: soul.
Speaker 1: So that means everything for the true
Speaker 1: seeker.
Speaker 1: What experience is that that I, what
Speaker 1: experience is that that I can find that can
Speaker 1: liberate me radically, absolutely,
Speaker 1: completely, permanently, totally, once and
Speaker 1: for all and forever?
Speaker 1: It means a lot.
Speaker 1: So the fact that this mystery exists and
Speaker 1: that it can be experienced, but not
Speaker 1: understood with the mind, is why it makes
Speaker 1: it so challenging.
Speaker 1: So I want to try and talk about what this
Speaker 1: actually means If we speak, because when
Speaker 1: I'm referring to non-duality or the
Speaker 1: ultimate truth, I'm speaking about the
Speaker 1: ultimate answer that sets us free, the
Speaker 1: ultimate answer to all spiritual questions,
Speaker 1: metaphysical questions, religious questions
Speaker 1: what's the ultimate answer that will really
Speaker 1: liberate us and level up our souls?
Speaker 1: So in the great religious traditions would
Speaker 1: be the word oneness To mean oneness.
Speaker 1: Often we speak of God, we speak of an
Speaker 1: anthropomorphic expression of oneness as a
Speaker 1: cosmic being, as a cosmic being with whom
Speaker 1: we can have a relationship with, and it is
Speaker 1: said by true believers that this cosmic
Speaker 1: being is the primary and fundamental
Speaker 1: creative force, not in the universe but as
Speaker 1: the universe, that this cosmic being is
Speaker 1: everything and also created everything, is
Speaker 1: everything and is always, always creating
Speaker 1: everything also.
Speaker 1: So when you can think of oneness more as a
Speaker 1: cosmic being than as a mysterious, formless,
Speaker 1: shapeless nothingness, it's much easier for
Speaker 1: the mind and we can think about these
Speaker 1: concepts or these higher truths in many
Speaker 1: different ways.
Speaker 1: Whatever will be helpful to us, higher
Speaker 1: truths in many different ways, whatever
Speaker 1: will be helpful to us.
Speaker 1: But this evening, or where I am this
Speaker 1: evening, I want to try and focus not on God
Speaker 1: as the principle, as the cosmic being, but
Speaker 1: as the ultimate nature of reality, the
Speaker 1: ultimate nature of reality.
Speaker 1: The ultimate nature of reality, the
Speaker 1: ultimate nature of reality, as I understand,
Speaker 1: would have to include everything that
Speaker 1: exists and simultaneously transcend
Speaker 1: everything that exists at the same time.
Speaker 1: So, if we want to begin to think about this
Speaker 1: a little bit, what is it that does or could
Speaker 1: include everything that exists, absolutely
Speaker 1: everything, seen and unseen, known and
Speaker 1: unknown, manifest and unmanifest, and
Speaker 1: simultaneously transcend it all at the same
Speaker 1: time?
Speaker 1: This is kind of a transrational cognition.
Speaker 1: It's a transrational knowing.
Speaker 1: It's a knowing of a great mystery that
Speaker 1: reveals itself to us when the mind begins
Speaker 1: to quiet down and recede into the
Speaker 1: background.
Speaker 1: So the awakening to enlightened awareness
Speaker 1: or the experience of enlightened awareness,
Speaker 1: so the awakening to enlightened awareness
Speaker 1: or the experience of enlightened awareness
Speaker 1: emerges in our consciousness when our
Speaker 1: rational faculties calm down and quiet down,
Speaker 1: especially if we're yearning for it.
Speaker 1: We really want to know what the truth,
Speaker 1: We really want to know what the truth is,
Speaker 1: if we're yearning for the God principle or
Speaker 1: this absolute principle to reveal itself to
Speaker 1: us, if we're yearning for revelation, if
Speaker 1: we're yearning for intimacy with the
Speaker 1: absolute, which is an important part of
Speaker 1: being a truth seeker, is the metaphysical
Speaker 1: yearning metaphysical burning, metaphysical
Speaker 1: torment to be one with one's maker, to be
Speaker 1: one with the absolute truth, the yearning
Speaker 1: to find a way to be at home in the universe.
Speaker 1: And ultimately, the only way to be truly at
Speaker 1: home here is to discover what the ultimate
Speaker 1: principle behind the created and the
Speaker 1: uncreated is and to merge with it, or to
Speaker 1: realize and experience.
Speaker 1: And it's fundamentally about relationship
Speaker 1: on so many levels at the same time.
Speaker 1: It's about so much of our conscious
Speaker 1: experience of being human exists in a
Speaker 1: dualistic context and framework, multiple
Speaker 1: dimensions at the same time, and so many
Speaker 1: relationships happening within us.
Speaker 1: But it seems that when it comes to the
Speaker 1: ultimate question, but it seems that when
Speaker 1: it comes to the ultimate question of
Speaker 1: ultimacy, that there is a truth, that the
Speaker 1: truth that liberates us is beyond the
Speaker 1: notion of any duality or relationship at
Speaker 1: all.
Speaker 1: And why this is so magnificent and deeply
Speaker 1: challenging is because it seems that,
Speaker 1: ultimately, if we want to be free, if we
Speaker 1: want to know the truth, if we want to be
Speaker 1: one with our maker, one with this absolute
Speaker 1: principle, we ultimately have to let go of
Speaker 1: the notion of any relationship with him or
Speaker 1: her at any level.
Speaker 1: So it would seem that letting go of the
Speaker 1: need to have that relationship at the
Speaker 1: deepest level of our being would make us
Speaker 1: available to know who or what he or she
Speaker 1: actually is.
Speaker 1: And it seems that the most sophisticated at
Speaker 1: least in my understanding, seems that the
Speaker 1: most sophisticated level of realization,
Speaker 1: realization of enlightened awareness, is
Speaker 1: the understanding of how to sustain a level
Speaker 1: of intimacy, of cosmic intimacy, with the
Speaker 1: absolute principle which requires us to
Speaker 1: simultaneously let go of it, let go of him
Speaker 1: or her unconditionally, radically,
Speaker 1: absolutely, totally, completely, without
Speaker 1: reservation, hesitation, once and for all
Speaker 1: and forever, so that we can find and
Speaker 1: experience that intimacy, the deepest level
Speaker 1: of our being.
Speaker 1: And the reason why this is so spiritually
Speaker 1: challenging and metaphysically challenging
Speaker 1: is it requires a level of superhuman trust.
Speaker 1: We have to be able to, we have to find a
Speaker 1: way to be able to trust in the ultimate
Speaker 1: mystery that transcends life and death more
Speaker 1: than we trust in the ultimate mystery that
Speaker 1: transcends life and death more than we
Speaker 1: trust in anything else, even though that
Speaker 1: mystery is something that we can't touch
Speaker 1: and we can't see.
Speaker 1: It's a mystery we'll never be able to touch,
Speaker 1: we'll never be able to see, we'll never be
Speaker 1: able to hold On the level of the human
Speaker 1: personality and the ego.
Speaker 1: Transcendence is very much about this
Speaker 1: ultimate challenge of being able to trust
Speaker 1: in that which we cannot see unwaveringly
Speaker 1: and doubtlessly, passionately and eternally,
Speaker 1: seems to be the great trick.
Speaker 1: So my guru said to me once and I often
Speaker 1: repeat this teaching that the only
Speaker 1: difference between enlightenment and
Speaker 1: unenlightenment is doubt.
Speaker 1: And I was thinking really, the only
Speaker 1: difference between enlightenment and
Speaker 1: unenlightenment is doubt.
Speaker 1: I always thought prior to that, at least
Speaker 1: prior to him saying that, which was over 35
Speaker 1: years ago at this point, prior to hearing
Speaker 1: him make that statement, I always thought
Speaker 1: that the that enlightenment was an
Speaker 1: experience, a kind of the presence of a
Speaker 1: certain kind of metaphysical feeling or
Speaker 1: vibration.
Speaker 1: Or, yeah, I always thought enlightenment
Speaker 1: was an experience of some kind, a subtle
Speaker 1: experience, a profound, subtle experience
Speaker 1: of some kind, of some kind a subtle
Speaker 1: of some kind.
Speaker 1: And now he was telling me that
Speaker 1: enlightenment is not an experience, it's a
Speaker 1: relationship to the totality of reality in
Speaker 1: all its complexity, that is free from doubt.
Speaker 1: So what is the nature of a relationship
Speaker 1: with the totality of reality that is free
Speaker 1: from doubt?
Speaker 1: So what is the nature of a relationship
Speaker 1: with the totality of reality that's free
Speaker 1: from doubt?
Speaker 1: So I think it works something like this
Speaker 1: when you wake up, when we wake up, when we
Speaker 1: wake up in our moments of deepest insight
Speaker 1: and knowing and recognition about the
Speaker 1: ultimate truth, about the nature of reality,
Speaker 1: in those moments we realize that
Speaker 1: everything's okay.
Speaker 1: It doesn't mean everything's working out
Speaker 1: how our ego would like things to work out,
Speaker 1: but it means, at a much higher and deeper
Speaker 1: level, at a transcendental level, we can
Speaker 1: feel and experience the all-rightness of
Speaker 1: all things in a way that deeply liberates
Speaker 1: us from fear and attachment.
Speaker 1: We can feel and experience the all
Speaker 1: rightness of all things in a way that
Speaker 1: ultimately deeply liberates us from fear
Speaker 1: and attachment, which is what freedom is
Speaker 1: all about.
Speaker 1: So there is a connection between being
Speaker 1: doubtless about that friend that you'll
Speaker 1: never be able to see and the steep
Speaker 1: metaphysical, emotional, psychological, but
Speaker 1: more metaphysical relinquishment of
Speaker 1: attachment, and relinquishing our
Speaker 1: attachment to our fear, to our self concern
Speaker 1: and to our existential anxiety about
Speaker 1: existence itself.
Speaker 1: There's something inexplicably profound
Speaker 1: about being so sure that, at the highest
Speaker 1: level, everything's okay.
Speaker 1: It allows us to be, to experience freedom
Speaker 1: in the midst of chaos and insecurity.
Speaker 1: This is very important because, ultimately,
Speaker 1: liberation is also about the soul, and is
Speaker 1: our soul going to be liberated?
Speaker 1: Are we going to experience liberation at
Speaker 1: the level.
Speaker 1: Is our soul going to be liberated?
Speaker 1: Are we going to experience liberation at
Speaker 1: the level of our own soul when we die, or
Speaker 1: are we going to go?
Speaker 1: Oh my God, what a mess I've made.
Speaker 1: So much is unresolved.
Speaker 1: I've got to go back and do it again.
Speaker 1: This is very much about ultimacy and what
Speaker 1: the consciousness and cognizance of
Speaker 1: ultimacy has to do with our relationship to
Speaker 1: life in the biggest sense of what that
Speaker 1: actually means, in the biggest sense of
Speaker 1: what that actually means.
Speaker 1: So, at the level of the soul, are we always
Speaker 1: already convinced that it's okay or are we
Speaker 1: living in fear, confusion, anxiety and
Speaker 1: frustration and terror?
Speaker 1: So are we?
Speaker 1: Have we found that friend?
Speaker 1: I'll never be able to sleep because when
Speaker 1: you do find that friend, when the friend
Speaker 1: does appear, and sometimes for the truth
Speaker 1: seeker, most truth seekers have
Speaker 1: breakthrough experiences which permanently
Speaker 1: transform their relationship to life.
Speaker 1: Breakthrough experiences actually change us.
Speaker 1: A lot of people have many breakthrough,
Speaker 1: many breakthrough experiences that make a
Speaker 1: deep metaphysical impression to the level
Speaker 1: of the soul, but they don't change us
Speaker 1: necessarily.
Speaker 1: And the deep into deep breakthrough
Speaker 1: experiences actually change us in a
Speaker 1: fundamental way.
Speaker 1: The experience is deep enough.
Speaker 1: It means that once this breakthrough has
Speaker 1: occurred.
Speaker 1: We're not the same person anymore because
Speaker 1: we've seen something and the seeing of
Speaker 1: which has permanently altered our soul's
Speaker 1: relationship to the existence of this body,
Speaker 1: ultimately altered our soul's relationship
Speaker 1: to the existence of this body.
Speaker 1: Because once you deeply know, once you
Speaker 1: deeply know and you know that you know
Speaker 1: you're not the same person anymore.
Speaker 1: And do we have the courage, once we've seen
Speaker 1: so deeply into the ultimate nature of
Speaker 1: reality, never to doubt the non-relative or
Speaker 1: ultimate truth about what we've seen, will
Speaker 1: we become scared and fearful and recoil in
Speaker 1: fear and doubt, because not to doubt and
Speaker 1: recoil in fear and doubt, because not to
Speaker 1: doubt requires enormous courage and faith,
Speaker 1: faith in the ultimate truth that we can't
Speaker 1: see.
Speaker 1: So, while the awakening to non-duality,
Speaker 1: which is the ultimate truth that transcends
Speaker 1: life and death, is an actual metaphysical
Speaker 1: experience, it's attainable and realizable.
Speaker 1: Being able to sustain that spiritual
Speaker 1: self-confidence that comes from such an
Speaker 1: event requires a very high degree of faith,
Speaker 1: and faith means being doubtless about that
Speaker 1: which we can't prove, that which we can't
Speaker 1: touch or taste or see with our eyes.
Speaker 1: So being doubtless about what we can't see
Speaker 1: is the key to spiritual self-confidence as
Speaker 1: the result of awakening to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness.
Speaker 1: It took me a long time to understand what
Speaker 1: the Master meant about the difference
Speaker 1: between enlightenment and unenlightenment
Speaker 1: is doubt.
Speaker 1: I said, really that's it.
Speaker 1: Get back to what I was speaking about a few
Speaker 1: minutes ago.
Speaker 1: It's not about the presence or lack of
Speaker 1: presence of a particular feeling, a
Speaker 1: particular vibration.
Speaker 1: No, once you know, and you know that you
Speaker 1: have known because if you have, if you have
Speaker 1: known, if you have experienced revelation
Speaker 1: of the highest order and you realize this
Speaker 1: is it, this is the truth, I realize what
Speaker 1: I'm saying is very audacious, but I can't
Speaker 1: help it, I've got to say it when you
Speaker 1: realize you've seen it, you've experienced
Speaker 1: it, you've tasted it and it's touched you,
Speaker 1: is that experience enough to convince you
Speaker 1: at a soul level that you've seen it, or
Speaker 1: will you recoil in doubt and terror and
Speaker 1: confusion and self-obsession and need to
Speaker 1: have another experience to prove it to you
Speaker 1: again?
Speaker 1: And then, when it happens a second time,
Speaker 1: will that be enough for you to believe it
Speaker 1: or will you need to be convinced by another
Speaker 1: experience yet again?
Speaker 1: Because if enlightenment means anything at
Speaker 1: all, it means that we already know, that we
Speaker 1: know, and the confidence in that knowing is
Speaker 1: not dependent upon any particular kind of
Speaker 1: the presence of any particular kind of
Speaker 1: feeling, any particular kind of vibration,
Speaker 1: presence of any particular kind of feeling,
Speaker 1: any particular kind of vibration or
Speaker 1: experience, even though, uh, paradoxically,
Speaker 1: of course, people in whom people, in whom
Speaker 1: people who have been deeply touched by this
Speaker 1: mystery, touching the way that is, that is
Speaker 1: rare and profound and deep and
Speaker 1: transformational usually become portals
Speaker 1: themselves to this mystery.
Speaker 1: The body, mind and the personality of such
Speaker 1: individuals become portals.
Speaker 1: They become because they have access.
Speaker 1: Now this mystery has penetrated their soul
Speaker 1: so deeply, but now the mystery itself
Speaker 1: speaks through them, because the mystery
Speaker 1: has its own voice and this ultimate mystery
Speaker 1: that's enlightenment is seeking for a way
Speaker 1: to be heard, to be seen, to be recognized
Speaker 1: by more and more of us.
Speaker 1: As I've often said, consciousness delights
Speaker 1: in its own self-recognition, consciousness
Speaker 1: delights in its own self-recognition.
Speaker 1: So consciousness is seeking for its own
Speaker 1: self-recognition through us.
Speaker 1: And when consciousness bursts through a
Speaker 1: worthy and sincere soul, the realization is,
Speaker 1: even if that hole remains an open portal,
Speaker 1: the spirit itself and, paradoxically,
Speaker 1: spiritual vibrations and miracle and
Speaker 1: mystery of transmission of this kind of
Speaker 1: knowledge begins to pour forth through such
Speaker 1: individuals.
Speaker 1: And this will only happen when one is
Speaker 1: doubtless.
Speaker 1: It's not dependent upon having a particular
Speaker 1: experience, having a particular kind of
Speaker 1: feeling pressing in a particular kind of
Speaker 1: knowing.
Speaker 1: It just means having no doubt, and having
Speaker 1: no doubt means, no matter what your
Speaker 1: experience is, you have no doubt.
Speaker 1: You have no doubt if you're feeling good,
Speaker 1: you have no doubt if you're feeling
Speaker 1: miserable.
Speaker 1: It means your doubtlessness is not
Speaker 1: dependent upon your emotional states or the
Speaker 1: relative circumstances of your personal
Speaker 1: life.
Speaker 1: It's a doubtlessness that transcends
Speaker 1: duality and all relative circumstances.
Speaker 1: So so I wanted what I wanted to ask a lot
Speaker 1: of you to try and do, would be to to
Speaker 1: consider for yourselves what would it be
Speaker 1: like to have no doubt in an ultimate truth,
Speaker 1: in an ultimate ministry that you'll never?
Speaker 1: And how comfortable are you, or is your ego
Speaker 1: with not needing proof all the time?
Speaker 1: At which point in your own spiritual
Speaker 1: evolution, will knowing that you know be
Speaker 1: enough?
Speaker 1: Will knowing that you know be enough?
Speaker 1: And you don't need the God principle.
Speaker 1: She doesn't need to prove herself to you
Speaker 1: yet again, because now, because she already
Speaker 1: has revealed herself to you and you know
Speaker 1: she has you have no doubt that she has
Speaker 1: revealed herself to you completely and you
Speaker 1: don't need to be convinced again because
Speaker 1: you're already convinced Now.
Speaker 1: If you have that kind of spiritual
Speaker 1: self-confidence, you're going to become a
Speaker 1: powerful person, because you don't need God
Speaker 1: to prove herself to you yet again.
Speaker 1: To repeat what I was saying earlier, too
Speaker 1: many of us need it to be proved to us again
Speaker 1: and I think the ultimate truth about the
Speaker 1: nature of reality, which is the God
Speaker 1: principle, needs, in this miserable world
Speaker 1: for more and more of us to be able to bear
Speaker 1: witness to her presence, to her radiant
Speaker 1: presence, to her existence, to her own
Speaker 1: doubtlessness in the face of fear and
Speaker 1: multiple dimensions of duality, chaos and
Speaker 1: conflict.
Speaker 1: You know, at the beginning of the path,
Speaker 1: we're in this for our own benefit, for our
Speaker 1: own liberation, which is understandable.
Speaker 1: But at a certain point we begin to realize
Speaker 1: that the God force, this esoteric or
Speaker 1: metaphysical principle in the cosmos, very
Speaker 1: much needs us to bear witness to her
Speaker 1: presence, not for our own sake, but for
Speaker 1: everybody else's sake, because the God
Speaker 1: principle doesn't exist up there.
Speaker 1: The God principle doesn't exist up there.
Speaker 1: She exists here and here and everywhere.
Speaker 1: And it's up to us as realizers, as awakened
Speaker 1: realizers, to bear witness to that fact, to
Speaker 1: be doubtless in the face of doubt, and it's
Speaker 1: a big part of what living the spiritual
Speaker 1: life in earnest is all about, isn't it?
Speaker 1: Being doubtless?
Speaker 1: The ego always creates doubt and
Speaker 1: self-concern.
Speaker 1: And from the perspective of enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness, doubt and self-concern is a big,
Speaker 1: overwhelming distraction from the ultimate
Speaker 1: truth.
Speaker 1: And we don't have an infinite amount of
Speaker 1: time to do this.
Speaker 1: Let's say, if we're going to live here 80,
Speaker 1: 90 years, how much time are we going to
Speaker 1: spend with self-concern and our ego story?
Speaker 1: At a certain point we need to make room for
Speaker 1: this God principle in our body, mind and
Speaker 1: personality.
Speaker 1: We have to make room for her to make
Speaker 1: herself comfortable in our home and let her
Speaker 1: have the big chair and let her have the big
Speaker 1: share, let her be the one who bears witness
Speaker 1: to this cosmic unfolding through us and
Speaker 1: have the courage to get out of the way.
Speaker 1: So, in terms of becoming doubtless, can you,
Speaker 1: can you trust unconditionally in what
Speaker 1: you've already realized is the ultimate
Speaker 1: truth and leave it alone, absolutely and
Speaker 1: completely?
Speaker 1: But you don't need to check to make sure
Speaker 1: she's still there Because, as I was
Speaker 1: explaining how this paradox works a few
Speaker 1: minutes ago, it's by letting go of our
Speaker 1: obsession with her and our doubts about
Speaker 1: whether she actually exists or not so
Speaker 1: leaving all that alone absolutely that she
Speaker 1: reveals herself to us in the deepest and
Speaker 1: most profound way imaginable.
Speaker 1: But in a sense, we have to prove ourselves
Speaker 1: first.
Speaker 1: We have to prove, in a sense, our faith and
Speaker 1: our worthiness to her first, because she
Speaker 1: will be able to give us the spiritual
Speaker 1: self-confidence that changes everything.
Speaker 1: So, getting back to what we were speaking
Speaker 1: about earlier, about oneness at the
Speaker 1: beginning of my talk, I find oneness a very
Speaker 1: confusing metaphor, because it's at least
Speaker 1: in the way that I think about it, and the
Speaker 1: fault might be mine and not yours.
Speaker 1: Oneness encourages me to think about the
Speaker 1: relationship between one thing and another,
Speaker 1: all the things that exist in the universe.
Speaker 1: It means that I tend to think that oneness
Speaker 1: means all things that exist as appearing to
Speaker 1: be separate, are all made of the same stuff.
Speaker 1: Because they're all made of the same stuff,
Speaker 1: they're not separate, which, from a physics
Speaker 1: point of view, might actually be true, but
Speaker 1: it's beside the point, because non-duality
Speaker 1: points to a non-materialistic, ultimately
Speaker 1: radical realization and cognition about the
Speaker 1: nature of consciousness in a way that
Speaker 1: cannot be cognized, it cannot be understood
Speaker 1: with the mind at all.
Speaker 1: So, as I've been saying, the only way to
Speaker 1: understand it is to let go of it.
Speaker 1: Not to let go of it, to forget about it,
Speaker 1: but to let go of it so we can become more
Speaker 1: intimate with it which is a paradox, I know,
Speaker 1: but that's how it actually works to become
Speaker 1: so, so absolutely confident that we can let
Speaker 1: go completely of our attachment to God.
Speaker 1: And through letting go of our attachment to
Speaker 1: God, through letting go of that attachment,
Speaker 1: she reveals herself in the deepest way to
Speaker 1: us.
Speaker 1: But this is something we actually have to
Speaker 1: do.
Speaker 1: So a lot of spiritual practice these days
Speaker 1: has become very psychological.
Speaker 1: It's about emotional, psychological
Speaker 1: well-being, working on our places.
Speaker 1: We've been hurt and maybe still hurting,
Speaker 1: but that has nothing to do with God.
Speaker 1: Realization God's never been hurt, wounded
Speaker 1: or traumatized or victimized ever by anyone,
Speaker 1: anywhere in her infinite existence and
Speaker 1: non-existence, because she's always free.
Speaker 1: And if she is me at the highest level and
Speaker 1: she is you, it means at the highest level.
Speaker 1: None of us have ever been hurt, wounded,
Speaker 1: traumatized or victimized either, even
Speaker 1: though we may have been severely so on a
Speaker 1: relative level, on an absolute level, it
Speaker 1: never happened.
Speaker 1: And at a certain point in these 80 or 90 or
Speaker 1: 100 years that we're going to be living, we
Speaker 1: might have to make a decision about whose
Speaker 1: life we want to be living.
Speaker 1: Do we want to be living the life of the
Speaker 1: small self, which is relative, personal
Speaker 1: self, which is relative, or the absolute
Speaker 1: self, which is relative.
Speaker 1: Personal self, which is relative, or the
Speaker 1: absolute self, which is non-relative and
Speaker 1: truly cosmic Literally I'm not exaggerating.
Speaker 1: When you really wake up, you realize who I
Speaker 1: have always been, who we have always been,
Speaker 1: who you have always been Is a cosmically
Speaker 1: conscious being who's awakening to him or
Speaker 1: herself and bearing witness to him or
Speaker 1: herself through the body, mind personality
Speaker 1: of yourself and myself and my body mind
Speaker 1: personality and your body mind personality
Speaker 1: are relative appearances with relative
Speaker 1: stories that are relatively interesting,
Speaker 1: but not absolutely interesting and not
Speaker 1: absolutely liberating, but not absolutely
Speaker 1: interesting and not absolutely liberating.
Speaker 1: The personal self is relatively interesting,
Speaker 1: the absolute self is absolutely liberating.
Speaker 1: And I think at a certain point in our
Speaker 1: spiritual this is my opinion at a certain
Speaker 1: point in our spiritual practice, we have to
Speaker 1: make a decision about which way we want to
Speaker 1: go and who we want to be.
Speaker 1: Remember, the absolute includes the
Speaker 1: personal, but the personal doesn't include
Speaker 1: the absolute.
Speaker 1: I'll say that again in case anybody missed
Speaker 1: it the absolute includes the personal, but
Speaker 1: the personal doesn't include the absolute.
Speaker 1: And I'll say it one more time, just for
Speaker 1: emphasis the absolute includes the personal,
Speaker 1: but the personal does not include the
Speaker 1: absolute.
Speaker 1: So that's why I would encourage everybody
Speaker 1: who resonates with what I'm saying to I
Speaker 1: wanted to encourage you to make a decision
Speaker 1: about which way you want to go with your
Speaker 1: life, with this body, mind and personality.
Speaker 1: Which dimension of the reality of being
Speaker 1: human do you want to give the greatest
Speaker 1: emphasis to and the greatest importance to
Speaker 1: you?
Speaker 1: So it takes a lot of courage to have no
Speaker 1: doubt.
Speaker 1: The ego becomes obsessed with doubt,
Speaker 1: tormented by doubt, tortures itself with
Speaker 1: doubt, and so it requires an enormous
Speaker 1: amount of spiritual self-discipline,
Speaker 1: renunciation.
Speaker 1: Remember that spiritual practice that would
Speaker 1: awaken us to enlightened awareness is
Speaker 1: always about renunciation, which means
Speaker 1: letting go of whatever is in the way.
Speaker 1: Not working it out, but letting it go.
Speaker 1: Not working it out, but letting it go, as
Speaker 1: my guru told me, quoting the Buddha, he
Speaker 1: said as nirvana has no beginning and no end,
Speaker 1: so samsara has no beginning and no end.
Speaker 1: So think of this life that you're living
Speaker 1: right now that's manifesting within a world
Speaker 1: space.
Speaker 1: This life that I'm living, that Andrew's
Speaker 1: living, or any one of you are living, is
Speaker 1: manifesting itself in a world space, and
Speaker 1: there is a world space that is a nirvanic
Speaker 1: world space that actually exists.
Speaker 1: That's why the Buddha spoke a nirvanic
Speaker 1: That's why the buddha spoke about nirvana
Speaker 1: because it actually exists.
Speaker 1: Nirvana is real.
Speaker 1: A lot of people don't believe it.
Speaker 1: And why should you believe it?
Speaker 1: If you, if you live in a samsaric world
Speaker 1: space, with the majority of your emotional
Speaker 1: and psychological and psychic experience
Speaker 1: occurs in a kind of hellacious world space
Speaker 1: that seems to be eternal, why should you
Speaker 1: believe in Nirvana?
Speaker 1: I don't blame you.
Speaker 1: Greatest realizers have reminded us,
Speaker 1: reminded us and repeatedly reflected back
Speaker 1: to us, that there is such a thing as a
Speaker 1: nirvanic world space that is also eternal.
Speaker 1: This is something that's very hard to
Speaker 1: understand with the mind, with the relative
Speaker 1: mind that thinks about everything in the
Speaker 1: short term.
Speaker 1: But when we, when we think about awakening
Speaker 1: to enlightened awareness and non-duality
Speaker 1: and spiritual realization, we want to think
Speaker 1: in terms of time and in a context of
Speaker 1: eternity.
Speaker 1: So this phrase of the statement, as nirvana
Speaker 1: has no beginning in no end, so samsara has
Speaker 1: no beginning in no end.
Speaker 1: I would encourage you, to all of you, to
Speaker 1: pay attention, to notice how true this
Speaker 1: actually is, notice how, in your moments of
Speaker 1: most, your mind becomes the most bright.
Speaker 1: You find yourself suddenly awake and in
Speaker 1: touch with the deepest dimensions of
Speaker 1: reality.
Speaker 1: Then you realize that brightness is an echo
Speaker 1: or a reflection of the eternal nature of
Speaker 1: the absolute.
Speaker 1: It's the eternal nature of the absolute
Speaker 1: that is so.
Speaker 1: It speaks of liberation, speaks of an
Speaker 1: unconditional liberation, eternal freedom.
Speaker 1: It's available here and now.
Speaker 1: Reflect upon that in your own experience,
Speaker 1: in your own privacy, of your own mind.
Speaker 1: I see this experience is so significant
Speaker 1: because it speaks of the eternal dimension
Speaker 1: of reality that's timeless and the freedom
Speaker 1: that's eternal.
Speaker 1: And then when you fall out of that Neuronic
Speaker 1: realm Should you be so, should this, should
Speaker 1: that happen?
Speaker 1: Right, when you fall back into, fall back
Speaker 1: into relative reality notice that there are
Speaker 1: so many concepts and beliefs that we're
Speaker 1: holding unconsciously.
Speaker 1: It seemed to paint a picture that this is
Speaker 1: reality, that this misery and the causes of
Speaker 1: this misery and the source of this misery,
Speaker 1: the nature of this misery, is also eternal
Speaker 1: and that there's no way out.
Speaker 1: In the context of a samsaric world space,
Speaker 1: it seems that way, it feels that way, but
Speaker 1: when you wake up to the neurotic world
Speaker 1: space, you realize that was never true.
Speaker 1: There's different ways to think about the
Speaker 1: human experience, and I'm speaking only in
Speaker 1: the context of enlightenment, as I
Speaker 1: understand it, which is unique.
Speaker 1: But learn how to introspect on the nature
Speaker 1: of your own experience and ask yourself, in
Speaker 1: the midst of your different kinds of
Speaker 1: experiences you have throughout the day,
Speaker 1: what's the context in which these
Speaker 1: experiences are happening, what's the
Speaker 1: context in which I'm understanding, what's
Speaker 1: happening to me, what's happening inside me?
Speaker 1: Is this heaven or is this hell versus how?
Speaker 1: So the fundamental point I wanted to make
Speaker 1: giving this talk, no-transcript with that
Speaker 1: friend you'll never be able to see is, as
Speaker 1: I've been saying, by letting go of it, by
Speaker 1: having the spiritual courage, the
Speaker 1: metaphysical courage and the heroic faith
Speaker 1: to let go of it radically, absolutely and
Speaker 1: completely, like forgetting about it, sort
Speaker 1: of kind of like forgetting about it,
Speaker 1: letting, trusting in it so much that you
Speaker 1: can let go of it absolutely, completely,
Speaker 1: because he and she is always there.
Speaker 1: So we don't have to cling on to what's
Speaker 1: always there, because what's always there
Speaker 1: is always there.
Speaker 1: It doesn't need our attachment.
Speaker 1: That, on one hand, this is a paradox.
Speaker 1: On one hand, to achieve the greatest
Speaker 1: intimacy with the ultimate mystery that
Speaker 1: lies beyond life and death is to let go of
Speaker 1: it.
Speaker 1: Let go of it and forget about it.
Speaker 1: Can't really forget about it.
Speaker 1: Let go of it and forget about it, because
Speaker 1: it's almost like your right arm.
Speaker 1: You don't keep checking if your right arm
Speaker 1: is there, do you?
Speaker 1: Because you have no doubt that it's still
Speaker 1: there and it's going to be there when you
Speaker 1: wake up in the morning, that you don't have
Speaker 1: to keep checking on it.
Speaker 1: So that's one way it works when you wake up
Speaker 1: in the morning, that you don't have to keep
Speaker 1: checking on him.
Speaker 1: So that's one way it works.
Speaker 1: And that requires a very high degree of
Speaker 1: realization and enormous faith and enormous
Speaker 1: trust.
Speaker 1: Enormous faith and enormous trust in the
Speaker 1: friend you can never be able to see.
Speaker 1: But the other way to do it is a paradox,
Speaker 1: which is something I often speak about,
Speaker 1: which is becoming a fanatic, becoming
Speaker 1: absolutely, one-pointedly focused on
Speaker 1: awakening to this absolute principle, this
Speaker 1: friend you'll never be able to see, all the
Speaker 1: time, allowing it to become more important
Speaker 1: to you than anything else and making sure
Speaker 1: that your mind never wavers or your mind
Speaker 1: never wanders, that you never forget about
Speaker 1: it.
Speaker 1: You become a true devotee of the absolute.
Speaker 1: You're always focused on her, always
Speaker 1: focused on her, and anything and everything
Speaker 1: else in this world, including your own mind,
Speaker 1: is always secondary.
Speaker 1: Your own ego and your own mind is always
Speaker 1: secondary and what's always primary to you
Speaker 1: is her and your love and devotion and
Speaker 1: adoration of her.
Speaker 1: But both lead to the same result.
Speaker 1: We live in such a materialistic world these
Speaker 1: days, such a spiritually flat world space,
Speaker 1: that cultivating that kind of one-pointed
Speaker 1: devotion to this absolute principle is a
Speaker 1: little bit difficult in this world these
Speaker 1: days, at this time.
Speaker 1: But it doesn't mean it can't be done.
Speaker 1: It doesn't mean it can't be done.
Speaker 1: And remember I'm almost finished, and
Speaker 1: remember that.
Speaker 1: Remember the non-duality which is what this
Speaker 1: talk is supposed to be about, is something
Speaker 1: that can't be understood by the mind.
Speaker 1: So if we spend too much time thinking about
Speaker 1: it, we can be sure we're gonna be off on
Speaker 1: the wrong track.
Speaker 1: And the problem is so much of our
Speaker 1: relationship to conscious existence is
Speaker 1: predicated through the mind, takes place
Speaker 1: through the mind, and that this mysterious
Speaker 1: process of waking up to consciousness and
Speaker 1: becoming conscious of consciousness and
Speaker 1: becoming conscious of these different
Speaker 1: dimensions of reality, relative and
Speaker 1: absolute, require the mind to be
Speaker 1: transcended absolutely, radically and
Speaker 1: completely.
Speaker 1: And no matter how much we may speak about
Speaker 1: transcending the mind, it's something
Speaker 1: that's not easy to do and that few people
Speaker 1: actually succeed at, because it's too hard
Speaker 1: for most of us to put in the effort to
Speaker 1: transcend the mind, it seems it's just too
Speaker 1: much of a struggle and most people give up.
Speaker 1: I tried for 10 minutes, I tried for a few
Speaker 1: minutes, but I didn't work, so I gave up.
Speaker 1: You know, for this to be able to work, you
Speaker 1: have to feel that your very existence
Speaker 1: depends upon figuring this out, working
Speaker 1: this out.
Speaker 1: There needs to be some a profound degree of
Speaker 1: metaphysical urgency.
Speaker 1: At present.
Speaker 1: You have to become convinced that unless I
Speaker 1: figure this out, unless I come to terms
Speaker 1: with this big question, life's never going
Speaker 1: to make sense and, most importantly, my
Speaker 1: life is never going to make sense.
Speaker 1: And only then will you find the level of
Speaker 1: urgency and the kind of intensity of
Speaker 1: awakened spiritual passion and interest to
Speaker 1: do this spiritual work, the hard spiritual
Speaker 1: work that's necessary for all of us to do
Speaker 1: if this is going to be a successful
Speaker 1: endeavor.
Speaker 1: I heard you were interested in
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: How's it going?
Speaker 1: Did you succeed?
Speaker 1: It's possible to succeed.
Speaker 1: It's possible to get to the other side of
Speaker 1: the, to reach the yonder shore.
Speaker 1: Once we reach the yonder shore, should such
Speaker 1: a thing happen to us, it doesn't mean our
Speaker 1: spiritual work is over or that our soul has
Speaker 1: been ultimately and permanently purified,
Speaker 1: once and for all and forever, but it means
Speaker 1: that we are no longer living in this world
Speaker 1: for the same reasons everyone else is.
Speaker 1: We've flipped and we've found a completely
Speaker 1: different relationship to the human
Speaker 1: experience and the human existence.
Speaker 1: So have the courage to take your own
Speaker 1: potential for liberation seriously.
Speaker 1: You have to take, we have to be willing to
Speaker 1: take ourselves and our own potential for
Speaker 1: this very seriously.
Speaker 1: Very few people are going to be willing to
Speaker 1: take, take us seriously in this area of
Speaker 1: human potential.
Speaker 1: Most people don't take their own potential
Speaker 1: for awakening very seriously.
Speaker 1: They're too busy doing other things.
Speaker 1: So I'm just about to end this talk.
Speaker 1: But please, everybody, please, consider
Speaker 1: this question that I brought up what my
Speaker 1: guru said to me, that the only difference
Speaker 1: between enlightenment and unenlightenment
Speaker 1: is doubt.
Speaker 1: Could it really be that simple?
Speaker 1: Yes, said to me that the only difference
Speaker 1: between enlightenment and unenlightenment
Speaker 1: is doubt.
Speaker 1: Could it really be that simple?
Speaker 1: Yes, it is you, you.